eux n'en démordent pas une trentaine de
parents opposés aux masques à l'école
ont manifesté avant-hier à tours pour ce
collectif le masque ne protège pas les
enfants du coc vide pire ils auraient
des effets nocifs sur la santé et
l'apprentissage
audrey champigny affublés de masques
vénitiens ou de super héros une petite
trentaine de parents et enfants se sont
fait entendre dans les rues de tours
pancartes et banderoles à l'appui il
dénonce l'inutilité de porter un masque
à l'école pour les tout petits on a
l'illusion que le masque vallée protégée
or on sait très bien qu'un enfant
pendant huit heures dans la journée va
toucher son masque une vingtaine de fois
il va leur montée il va l'enlever pour
aller boire il va l'enlever pour aller
manger et donc on sait que un mastic est
mal utilisée il va pas être protecteur
le collectif de parents d'élèves pointe
du doigt également les effets nocifs sur
la santé de leurs enfants
malaise buée sur les lunettes qui
empêche de voir au tableau ou encore
allergies cutanées
j'aime pas trop ça parce que pas parce
que j'ai des fois je m'essouffle un peu
ça les gêne et je mets souvent souligné
ben chang chen pas si tous suisse
respire un peu mal sama empêchent de
bien travailler enfin la somme de ça me
met à la teste et du coup j'ai du mal à
me concentrer
certains parents profitent du mouvement
pour partager leurs positions plus
radicales
n'ayant pas peur de parler de
manipulation de la part du gouvernement
et ces mesures liberticides
à l'extérieur le port du masque est
contre-productif et non non je ne suis
pas d'accord
parce qu'il ya des études qui le prouve
en extérieur la charge virale ne reste
pas en suspension lll circulent il faut
une certaine concentration de charge
virale pour qu'on puisse être familier
par cette charge donc en extérieur c'est
absolument contre productif ça n'a aucun
intérêt
le collectif qui espérait compter plus
de monde dans ses rangs pour ce premier
rassemblement n'exclut pas de renouveler
l'expérience